tout le monde sait squeeze aujourd'hui
on se retrouve sur un jour agents
géométrie d'âge c'est sur ipad il paraît
que c'est très rageant un peu comme la
rentrée vous allez boulot bâtard c'est
parti plage est absolument jamais joué
mais j'en ai énormément entendu parler
c'est parti on va commencer par le début
un histoire d'apprendre un peu c'est
parti
wow c'est non mais non mais j'avais pas
le droit il ya un pic sur sur 100 m je
me le prends c'est pas mal à ce qui se
passe non mais non mais c'est ce douala
il a bon elle non non mais en baisse de
niveau 1
c'est hors de question de passer ni vos
injures fusent des cuillères refus
catégorique à temps mais ça c mais ça
c'est niveau mais c'est scandaleux
non mais mais je suis d'une nullité en
plus la musique elle commence à partir
je sentis dans ma tête qu'ils avaient un
petit feeling un peu comme ça la up
je déteste ce bruit mais je pense qu'il
faut juste le prendre en main puis
ensuite tu es bon quoi mais vous même
pas comme ça par exemple d'accord sa
part sur un missile et les bons pilotes
à elle pas mauvais j'ai pas regardé la
cams qu'après ça partait sur un décès je
le sais on est carrément bon [ __ ] je
sais vous êtes fier de moi au nom 56%
mais j'ai besoin d'avoir joué pendant
une heure et demie et si on fait back on
track partout hasard attendez j'ai
désactivé la musique parce qu en fait
j'aime j'aime pas trop finalement je
vais l'appeler exprès c'est ça le pire
mais j'attends mes mecs non mais là y'a
un problème là là c'est la fatigue j'ai
mis la fatigue et les excuses de tous je
crois en nous mais mais mais je suis nul
mais je m'énerve - m mais le cas là je
mais c'est un truc de dingue en dessous
hop hop hop hop
[Musique]
j ai pas vus ja il était tapi dans
l'ombre le triangle
il faut que vous fassiez confiance il
faut que je vous fasse confiance il faut
que tout le monde se fasse confiance se
passe plein de bisous non ça n'a rien à
voir
je sais qu'on peut le faire je sais
qu'on peut le faire [ __ ] à des gens
qui font ça mais ici pourquoi pas moi je
me suis fait mal à la tête
oh oui oh oui et non mais ils sont
mignons s'était même pas les pics et
d'aider tout s'est pas tu sais pas ce
que c'était regardez c'est pas les pics
à plus tard c'est l'ombre des pics à
l'âge et au risque que sais-je content
non mais non mais non non je veux un
débat tout seul là quelqu'un y voir
d'inconvénient
non bon voilà au h où je pas dit qu'un
peu et voilà c'est [ __ ] je bannis en
fait je panique tout le temps la légende
passe la légende pas si pour vous c'est
pour vous ça peut être pour moi
enfin c'est un peu quand même des tirs
au but
je sais pas ce que c'est que ça mais je
le prends à mais c'est bien ça pour
s'entraîner pour les nuls c'est pas mal
aulas je veux pas je veux pas une
practice mal je passe votre pitié je
veux m'en sortir seuls kaka select c'est
notre personnage qui est mauvais on
regarde et lui sourit enfin et souris
sourire un peu blasé on va prendre lui
totalement blasé tout se passera bien
regarder aa non c'est impossible
or je crois s'appliquer je crois pas
paniqué et des mois et des mois et des
mois j'étais sur les partis il est pas
du tout aux puces celui là quand tu lui
dis un bug en plus et veut dire qu'il
est vraiment pas dur au aaa
c'était là hop là non pas quatre fois on
avec la musique j'ai besoin de faire
lobotomiser mais on a nommé la fois les
sous que la puissance de quiconque
viennent en moi parce que quiconque sur
le plus puissant que moi sur ce jeu
[ __ ] j'étais comme ça j'étais quand
même ça c'est trop pour justifie ni même
comme ça reprend même quand même ça ça
c'est pas bien je vais le faire à la
musique a changé quand même je suis
passé en mode aux entraînements pour les
nuls ou et même quand je fais pas exprès
le je me dis vas t'entraîner été nul
on n'a qu'à faire des bruits de joueur
de tennis à chaque fois que l'on saute
haut à aa
voilà je sais pas quoi faire j'aime bien
ce moment ces moments de repos un peu
qui s'est déjà pris les flics ici
absolument personne cela est impossible
je me gratte date empêché d'ans même
temps aulas lors le joueur pro le
géométrie d'âge pgm on n'est jamais allé
juge non salut je suis leonardo dicaprio
avec un million fois moins de style
est ce que cette musique ne passerait
pas carrément bien sûr un discours un
peu avec de l'émotion voilà les amis
j'ai eu mon diplôme je vous quitte pour
aller travailler
et là il s'en va comme ça avec une cape
de superman on sait pas pourquoi et ses
amis sont là avec leur mac do dans les
mains et le regardent bizarrement et se
disent atome c qui lui ce pas notre ami
ne connaît pas non voilà l'histoire qui
me coûte à elle vit à chaque fois mais
le décor à parler une nouvelle couleur
ah oui oh oui là là on va y aller c'est
sur la puissance des yeux et de la
bouche violette je me suis préparé toute
ma vie pour finalement réussir cette
étape importante aussi importante qui
est aux ordres son linge à passer le
niveau 1 de géométrie dash au nom j'ai
failli perdre failli perdre
non mais tu le caches tu en as mais quel
con non oui oui oui
changeons niveau j'en ai marre de ce
niveau olympio l'os mais je suis nulle
naturellement on a trouvé le jeu où je
suis plus du lot aa à aa tout va bien se
passer
aux 400 est une petite victoire
là je perds le fil il faut faire infuser
pendant 5 secondes
ah voilà là c'est une manière d'exprimer
son mécontentement
si vous pensez qu'il ya des gens quand
ils viennent de télécharger le jeu il
joue et puis et passe les niveaux 1 2 3
4 comme ça tranquillement sans aucune
difficulté est ce que vous pensez que
ces gens ont le pseudo squeeze non
seulement à moi je pense pas déjà
autorise trahi non comme si je meurs
j'appuie j'aimerais bien fait en fait là
j'ai plus envie de connaître la suite de
la chanson que de connaître la suite de
niveaux en fait ça quand je vais sur
itunes je la trouve l'achète et puis il
faut que je veux que le jeu euros mais
pourquoi je me le prends verhille gilles
jusqu'au bout
mais pourquoi je suis ce qu'indique
semaine bus ça c'est pour moi c'est
gratuit c'est quoi
moi je trouve ça presque un peu trop
simple voilà un club premier soul mais
la pression devrait commencer au gm ce
qui va mal passé choc ya un petit
feeling entre moi et ce niveau voilà je
vais proposer de venir avec mon
restaurant un peu de fois j'ai des
petites phrases ou mon cerveau il se met
à comprendre il fait à oui comme ça
oh non mais c'est très rare par exemple
un lait il a décoché ok ok le progrès
non le progrès arrive tu sais que ça non
[Musique]
je me suis étonnée je vous étonner
j'étais content parce que je suis niveau
3 et j'ai fait 13 % du niveau du premier
coup quoi je pense que là si on retourne
et vous ingérez vrai vingt sept ces
jours où je suis né c'est un signe
retournons niveau 1 est ce que j'ai
vraiment envie d'appuyer sur ce bouton
fait le faites le à moi je peux plus
faites le merci je vais nommer un papa
et une maman parmi vous qui seront
finalement mes coaches vous allez me
coacher vous allez me dire demain matin
tu vas faire 3 abdou un sudoku et tu vas
manger un peu de poulet le soir toujours
à géométrie dash et tu passeras le
niveau zéro nick mon âne salut bon c'est
tout pour géométrie d'âge pont cerveau
va littéralement exploser et c'est
dingue parce que vous avez été hyper
vont voir proposer jeu mais je pense que
je suis vraiment particulièrement nul à
mon avis le niveau 1 et doit pas être si
dur que ça je sais pas je n'arrive
absolument pas et je suis très frustré
actuellement c'est bon je suis plus
frustré désolé pour la durée de la vidéo
chez carlin qui trouve que parfois mes
vidéos sont trop courtes mais ça dépend
des fois celle des vidéos de 8 9 10
minutes des fois de cinq ou six minutes
ça dépend du jeu et l'a vu qu'il est pas
mal répétitives et il est vrai que je
rage ou si pas mal on va arrêter ne vous
en faites pas on se retrouve très vite
dans une nouvelle vidéo qu'elle soit
courte ou longue mais c'est d'avoir
regardé icho tout le monde dit ça
[Musique]
et